venneman spidey may very well meets on
the big screen again but even with this
much potential as the clash could have
there are plenty of reasons why far from
home is far from the right choice for
another meeting between the two here's a
look at the reasons why it probably
won't happen
Venom's obviously much darker of a
character than spider-man Eddie Brock
wouldn't let his symbiote kill cops and
venom but when it came to crooks he had
a more fluid moral compass his solo film
was pg-13 because the filmmakers left a
lot to the audience's imagination but
make no mistake he ate people heroes
killed bad guys in Marvel movies sure
Hawkeye's transformation into Ronin and
Avengers endgame was the darkest we've
seen any of their heroes go
but even then no hero in the MCU eats
people with Disney's acquisition of Fox
there are likely a lot of conversations
going on behind the scenes about content
for example we know Disney is interested
in more Deadpool movies and has pledged
not to water him down for younger
audiences but it's doubtful he'll be a
part of the larger MCU anytime soon
likewise it probably will be a bit
before Disney gives the thumbs up to
superheroes who eat muggers one of the
reasons spider-man and Venom's conflict
worked in the comics is that Parker and
Brock were in somewhat similar
situations they were roughly the same
age they were both journalists working
for New York area newspapers and largely
because of Brock's competitive nature
they were rivals the movie situation
isn't the same in venom Eddie Brock as
an established adult investigative
journalist Peter Parker hasn't graduated
high school yet imagining the MC use
version of Peter fighting alongside
someone like venom is a little tough in
the trailer for far from home he doesn't
even want to talk to Nick Fury on the
phone he's intimidated by fury so heed
he really feel comfortable working with
an oily pile of black slime that talks
like a gargling demon unlikely on my
planet I am kind of a loser like you but
here we could be more Spidey and venom
had met on screen before Topher Grace
starred as Eddie Brock in spider-man 3
and he wasn't alone his bill and his
character was joined by the new Goblin
and the Sandman there were so many
villains that Venom's eventual
appearance had to be held off until the
end where it was rushed and unsatisfied
and far from home we've already got
Mysterio and possibly hydro-man molds
man and the chameleon not to mention all
the rumors and theories about secret bad
guys most of them will be no-shows but
it's still clear there's no room for
venom Tony Stark has been an obvious
replacement for MCU Peter's absent
father and even Adrian Toomes acts like
a twisted parental figure and homecoming
from what we've seen a far from home the
filmmakers have seemingly set up Nick
Fury and Mysterio as dueling mentor
figures to be reoffer 'he's tough love
since we know Mysterio is a villain in
the comics he will probably be much
friendlier to gain Parker's trust
throwing venom in the mix would give us
one too many surrogate dads croc is like
most guys in this movie older than
Parker and has some abilities similar to
his once they stopped beating each other
up Peter would see him as another role
model and he's already got enough to
deal with in that department as the far
from home trailer indicates the MCU we
know might just be one small part of a
wider multiverse bik is from Earth just
not ours if this is true and the MCU is
about to open up in a similar way to
what we saw in spider-man into the
spider verse then maybe venom and the
upcoming Morbius take place in a kind of
parallel world
if Spidey winds up traveling through the
multiverse one of the places he visits
could be the world where venom
occasionally rides space shuttles but
there's also an alternate theory that
Mysterio is lying about being from
another earth and the multiverse has
nothing to do with what's going on in
part from home while Mysterio presents
himself as an ally of spider-man in the
trailers and TV spots is one of Spidey's
oldest villains with abilities involving
creating illusions to trick people
it's totally conceivable he's not only
tricking spider-man but Nick Fury as
well if that's the case then it would
seem to close the door on the theory
that venom might show up because of the
multiverse the venom movie not only
divorced Eddie Brock's story from Peter
Parker's it also established itself as a
horse all on its own inspiring
record-breaking ticket sales all those
profits helped venom establish a strong
start for its franchise with advance
ticket sales even outperforming a number
of successful MCU movies basically the
character has become an entity all of
his own independence of spider-man
you're welcome introducing venom to the
crowded MCU now when he's just starting
to make a name for himself could derail
things his solo franchise would suffer
if he's once again seen as merely a
Spidey spin-off give Tom Hardy another
movie or two with his symbiote buddy and
then maybe he'll be ready to co-star
with spider-man Eddie Brock learns early
in this most recent comic series that
his symbiote was on earth much earlier
than he believed and met a man named Rex
we'd been merged with the alien during
the Vietnam War
venom Madsen battled the space god named
null who held dominion over all
symbiotes and learned null had fought
for centuries before since these
revelations Venom's origin has taken on
a more cosmic scope if Marvel Studios
wants to add venom to its movies it may
want to wait until it gets the
opportunity to introduce these newer
grandeur aspects of his mythology
there's already a lot going on and far
from home know the all-black and
everything else would likely need their
own movies separate from Mysterio
multiverses and Peter Parker's newest
crush Disney has a deal with Sony which
holds the movie rights the spider-man
and related characters for spider-man to
be in the MCU that deal doesn't include
venom with a character to appear in a
Marvel Studios movie alongside
spider-man Sony would have to agree to
allow it when Marvel and Sony hammered
out their current spider-man deal Sony's
attempts at rebooting the spider-man
film franchise had failed they had a lot
of motivation to work with Marvel
Studios that isn't necessarily the case
with venom in spite of being an utter
disaster according to critics you are
pathologically self-absorbed and your
stubbornness helped venom made mountains
of money and while the character is
strongly associated with spider-man he
isn't so strongly tied to the rest of
the Marvel Universe arguably as far as
Sony's interests are concerned having
venom show up and far from home or any
other Marvel Studios film would serve
only to dilute the franchise so will we
get more venom definitely will he be
teaming up with spider-man probably not
at least not yet
even he invited us both like check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about spider-man
and friends are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]